how's it going there reject nation we
are going to watch episode three of
gravity falls today of season two if
you're here mean a lot if you could
subscribe and click that notification
bell to get notified when our next
reaction of gravity falls is up also uh
full length watch along as we stick up
with the time coder over at our patreon
page for our super sexy rejects thank
you guys so much for all who have joined
so far and uh if you can leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated as
always dipper and
over at prepper thank you boys and girls
there's no girls there girls here uh i
don't know what you guys look like
all right thanks for helping us
who down stand cakes they're like
pancakes but they probably have some of
my hair in them pass
oh gravity falls gossiper accepted my
article about summer fashion tips for
squirrels my picture is gonna be in the
newspaper pacifica northwest declares
phoenix the look of the season what am i
looking at here
no
no no
is it legal for a child to wear that
much makeup pacifica julie's ruins
everything ah cheer up mabel i mean no
one even reads newspapers anymore print
media is dying who wants to help me get
ahead of the fashion curve i'm taking it
one step further with the w-neck
must follow newspaper you're ahead of
your time zeus
i need something to get my mind off this
looking for a distraction from your
horrible life why yes victory that tv
man these old-timey-sounding words are
alive and well at the gravity falls
royal discount pothot no button
available at snack shop oh
jip she's been amazing at it since we
were kids
first place
come on mabel victory honor destiny
martin
victory
mountain
and the pig can look after the house
got the swaddles signs of gas i wonder
what gas prices are like in gravity
falls or like 9.50 a gallon
[Music]
heaven there's something here for
everyone
hey you stop
come back here
classic focus and
oh
my god you're still
extraordinary
i'll take what i can get
see the hip wiggle and
way to use geometry mabel
[Music]
how'd i get here yeah wow if mabel gets
a hole in one here she'll beat her
all-time high score you can do it
pretend the ball is pacifica's face
[Music]
[Music]
oh no what have you done now you're
worthless the thing's random yeah
besides the bermuda's triangle how many
golf works is the world's greatest
mystery as far as i'm concerned you're
still better than anyone else in gravity
oh would you look at that [ __ ] burn her
how's that whole your family being
frauds thing working out for you great
actually that's the thing about money it
makes problems go away so true
this is sergey my trainer this sport
olympics had mini golf once i took gold
oh
i want a rematch you you
walking one dimensional bleach blonde
valley girl stereotype
wow dang
you me midnight we'll see who's best
i'll be here
if you beat her at this she could never
rag on you again imagine it
um the section for ugly grandma clothes
is over there well the section for
people who lost it mini golf is over
there
we came as fast as we could
from the movie
you're right guys i just need to
practice a little more before midnight
go to the golf course after dark you say
i don't know we'd have to break in and
just kidding let's break it yeah that's
why i go
owen hey mabel okay
oh
darn pup
get it what is wrong with this hole
that's what she said
did you hear that what what is it
grab your club
oh
[Music]
oh my god
yes it's as i've always suspected
[Music]
are we good we good
i'm franz and welcome to our home what
is this yeah are you guys tiny humans or
enormous mini humans
the name makes more sense written out
than spoken and we control the balls
behold
no gulliver's mini golf oh my god is
mabel not talented
[Music]
what a charming rube goldberg machine
would you like us to elaborate through
songs
yes
yeah we're good
i have to play this golf tournament
against my rival pacifica
oh we know all about rivals put a clog
in at your windmill lovers
[Music]
[Music]
our flag means golf guys
oh no
oh no oh no if only there was some way
to decide which side is best with maybe
been a ward or like a trophy i don't
know but france luke
sticker
oh no i'm not sure i want to get
involved in your weird mini blood feud
this is perfect these guys control the
course just tell them we'll give the
sticker to whichever group does a better
job of helping us win
that's cheating doesn't this seem like
cheating that's exactly what it is she's
cheating at life
ha ha fair point we're going to have a
game of mini gold and whoever does the
best job helping me win gets the sticker
[Music]
spoon
there are a lot of stars out tonight
well this is getting weird
don't deny your love remember pacifica
winning is everything oh oh and also
looks winning in lux
[Laughter]
get set
[Music]
dang
[Music]
what
oh
no
oh my god but they're all helping you
mabel they're all the best
[Music]
minor hole
oh oh god
anyone who goes in there
henry
oh no
no
don't go big henry
[Music]
got this big henry
[Applause]
oh
pig henry
[Music]
oh sergey soda now hey hey little high
fives everyone little high fives all
around nice one you did it you're the
man no one's even grieving miners might
have one of these in their future
why don't you just print the stickers
after everything we've worked for calm
yourself franz there may be another way
to win the hugeling's favor knock on
wood
these clogs i can feel it maybe there
has little people who control where the
balls go
huh
i can't wait to see the look on
pacifica's face when we win i'm thinking
it'll be like
[Music]
trust me pacifico will be fine
what's going on here
gulliver's travels so we saw you were
favoring the miners and we figured
what's better than beating pacifica
killing her oh yeah if you're going to
play dirty so were we now give us the
sticker for he walks the plank no give
us this decal
[Music]
what have you done
tearing these people apart no one gets
the sticker sock ripe
maybe rivalries are dumb maybe you don't
settle them with petty competitions
maybe the only way to be the best is by
ending the fighting and working together
no that's not how it works man you just
destroyed your only bargaining chip
if we work together
then we could cut open her belly and get
the sticker
[Music]
[Laughter]
uh you guys aren't appreciating the
lesson here
just move on its own let her die gotta
get out of here
i have to save pacifica first now why
your problems will be solved
don't freak out man the water is shallow
there's literally no way to drown
no
no
it's mr glass you know on second thought
maybe i won't untie you untie me untie
me that's what i thought
you ready to putt way ahead of you
hey
you're actually not that terrible
a little rusty but
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh now it goes fast
[Music]
wow
[Music]
you guys did it i don't know what you
did or what's going on but if you think
just because you saved my life by
oh sorry pacifica we shouldn't have
cheated you totally would have beat me
fair and square
you're just lucky this sticker looks
fantastic on me ah
come on
you want a ride home
please as if i'd ride in your
singing
song
headlights are out there
oh gross
tacos
oh you're allowed to eat in the car
yeah want one oh i'm not supposed to
take handouts
oh
you do know what sharing is right
[Laughter]
[Music]
i had fun
and tell your servant i like his w neck
yes yes whose
i think we made some progress the
important thing to remember is that at
the end of the day she's just an
ordinary kid like us
yep
i should have charged her for that taco
agreed huh hey you got any more of those
surprise tacos
no
the real villain but franz will have his
day
franz will
oh
trap
they got the results
[Laughter]
oh captive audience just wait till the
morning
when all the kids show up
gravity falls is better than ever
just doesn't stop getting better this is
the best episode i think we've seen in
some time
which means season two is just killing
the game
because i feel like each episode of
season two has just been like that just
keeps leveling up and this one did huh
yeah this is very fun this this took a
motif i personally very much enjoying
cartoons
which is the small consortium of of you
know like miniature slaves people yeah
many slaves who run any given thing
whether it be you know some kind of
metaphysical brain space of a certain
character or a mini golf course like
this one love that lore love that
approach this is the best episode of the
season
and it won't get any better than this
the best guest star
best concept
best lesson learned maybe about cheating
just maybe just maybe
i think it's okay to cheat
always it's always okay to cheat unless
you get caught and then you didn't cheat
at all you can't prove anything
that's fine
i mean this is a
you know a more episodic one i feel like
they've they've gotten us to a point now
where there's a bigger expectation for
like oh the unraveling lore of what's
hidden under gravity falls and grunkle
stan's involvement and all that sort of
stuff
and uh yeah especially it's interesting
that this is the third episode because
the first two episodes felt so kind of
one flows into the other
especially out of the finale of last
season but uh
i don't know i thought this was
whimsical and fun good patton oswalt's
guest voice it was yeah it was cute it's
a cute episode with a strong commentary
on classism in america too which i
thought was really great you know
spoiled rich brat
uh pacifica playing and then you got all
these people
who are part of the lower class of
society just having to be like factory
workers essentially at the mini golf
course there's pawns for their game so i
i think that that is a really good
um educational programming here for the
children as well on what you can learn
i do i think i kind of actually
think about it
um
so the
the mini golf angle
mini golfers
can be fun
[Laughter]
but but
more often than not
the ones are very boring halfway through
it sounds more fun in theory than it is
prolongedly
it's actually more boring with more
people too oh yeah yeah cause then you
wait forever it's a good date activity
it's a good one-on-one activity
yeah
with the
cliche ribbing
making fun of it
uh acting like you're keeping score
actually mini golf is fun when you're
really playing with someone who's really
taking it serious and if you're not
taking it serious
but they are
it is so fun especially if you're
winning
well yeah because
you just watch them get so pr i play
mini golf
the most countless times and it usually
ends up being a really boring event it's
always it's always really fun in the
first 10 minutes
and then when you got to wait for the
group ahead of you
for like 25 minutes yeah
then you're like this is this is taking
longer than necessary it's not worth the
windmill and then when you can't get the
hole and the you can't get the ball in
the hole then it's like this is really
a waste of time
that's where i go i go my time is
precious
and when we move on with our lives right
about this fun center i agree yeah but
no i i i always want a mini golf that's
a problem it's an addiction
it's an addiction that's right and i got
a season pass always there pushing kids
out of the way there's a place called
sherman oaks castle park which has been
in our vicinity our entire lives
and
the the that's the i think it's the only
mini golf place nearby
is there
i can't think of one it's definitely the
closest one there's probably it's
probably a drive to get to the next
closest one yeah it's it's really
beautiful it's a beautiful mini golf
spot yeah as much as they've updated the
arcade like the actual mini golf has
sort of remained its classic self and
it's uh like three different courses
ah but god damn i would care for some
little people
oh yeah to be in there yeah well being
actual little people yep the actual uh
just a horde of little people who run
thing
like
no i'm not gonna say that but yeah yeah
yeah what were we gonna say uh
say it i was going to you know more real
little people than i so you are likely
to offend those more friends than myself
i have
one person at stake
you have several so yes yes so let's see
if your friendships remain intact ah
well you know i mean it would make it uh
sort of uh like a willy wonka type of
consortium where like everyone who works
there is a little person you shouldn't
have said that i'm not gonna say the o
word because i feel like that would
cross a line but you know who else has
an operation solely headed up by little
people wait is oompa loompa
a derogatory work i don't think so but i
feel like a lot of little people
probably have to endure being called
that because it's like some people's
probably earliest touchstone for the
fact that little people exist is
remembering willy wonka
wow i never thought of it that way
well
hey now you have and now you'll have to
work never to make that comparison again
i'm a progressive individual you are
so you're more progressive than me
i don't think
i don't know it depends on what we're
talking about
[Laughter]
i guess not i don't know
when we start the politics podcast we'll
figure that out but uh no well yeah this
was uh this was a fun detour this was
fun this is this was not my favorite but
it was a fun cute one with a good lesson
is the most i enjoyed pacifica yeah
and i weirdly did not correlate the
connection of a rivalry on the mini golf
course
um
linking to the rivalry between
pacifica and mabel i weirdly did not do
that and then when they got there i was
like ah that's what we're doing here
[Laughter]
settling this in a mutual
skill set
bam make off so so stressful such a
stressful activity yeah yeah those
little pencils keeping track of the
little pencil making sure you score it
right i don't have light for you to
write
no
no they have a one little designated
circular table underneath a couple lamps
that all inevitably have like spider
webs all over them
and the biggest spider you've ever seen
i don't know why many golf courses are
populated by the biggest ass spiders
you've ever seen but every time i've
been to one that's the case
so uh hey that didn't happen here at
least at least it wasn't icky
i've been hit on the head at mini golf a
few times tim
yes yeah i took a club directly in the
eye once
that's sorry
it's okay you know i
i can see a little bit
anyway
this is a thought-provoking episode yeah
dude i mean your your likening of this
to uh socioeconomic class struggles is
apt you know the the elites battle it
out in a frivolous game way above
everyone who has to actually run and
operate the means of
production and whatnot it's it's sale
it's more salient than i gave it credit
for and then you got sheeple like seuss
out here just buying the line coming in
from the rich class of all what kind of
neck is my shirt it doesn't matter man
it's just keep you complacent
while you know we enslave people for
mini golf to make mini golf happen
i think this episode would have been
better if they incorporated coven
definitely if the
the little people on the golf course
you know start off with one person
contracting the virus oh and they're
like it's nothing it's just a cold the
next thing you know you watch it spread
and then no one's winning the game
because all of the workers are sick and
then they have to
go to
the uh containment part of the golf
course yes the quarantine zone
oh
have their their shield masks on
everything yeah full face yeah mouth
mask and a face shield just in case so
we really see what's we really get a
stronger that way kids can really learn
yeah when are kids gonna start getting
the pandemic cartoon yeah you know
respirator uh cartoons see the funny
side of the pandemic that's right man
it's about time it's about time we
reflect and see the humor there yeah in
all the countless
lives
characters hey you could a little
microbial a little microbial get like a
a celebrity voice actually from his
perspective yeah totally totally get
will arnett to voice coven
or you could see this yeah right yeah it
would work it would work
i'm just gonna settle up into your body
here
oh that's nice i'm gonna make myself at
home i don't gender or discriminate
i'll get all you guys sick
it's funny i could hear will our net so
distinctly and yet my impression is just
it's it's a gravelly voice
i'm trying to get as a cadence but it's
kind of hard
that's good
all right guys thanks for being here
tell us in the comments down below do
you like mini golfing
would you have preferred this to
incorporate the pandemic
hey let's do a page
we got a shout out today anissa oliva
anisa
you're a freaking liar it was your
birthday recently did you wish her happy
birthday where are you
i wished her a happy birthday in advance
but i neglected to over the weekend
because i'm a bad friend and i don't
like you
but
it's only because i'm saving the wishes
for when i show up in person
to serenade you on your birthday well
you might as well give it to her now
anisa
happy birthday to you
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday
anisa
happy birthday
to you
and many more
wherever birthdays are sold
ending punch line
dope ah sanding punch line
[Music]
you